(clanging)
- [Narrator] Over the
course of human history,
fuel for industry has come in many forms.
But one of the major
drivers of development
in the current technological age
is a highly volatile element
that makes up only .002%
of the Earth's crust.
Such a rare commodity has
become the bedrock of industry
and may be the key to the
future of civilization.
Lithium, a soft, silver gray metal
is the third lightest
element in the universe.
Originally discovered in 1817
in a piece of volcanic stone,
lithium was named after the
Greek word for stone, lithos.
Every since its discovery,
lithium has been found to
be incredibly versatile
including strengthening glass
and refining metal alloys
but probably the most
popular use of lithium
is in lithium batteries.
Holding a charge for longer
than traditional batteries,
lithium batteries are often used
to power devices as small
as smartphones and laptops
and as large as electric vehicles.
The versatility of lithium
has helped catapult many
technological developments
largely due to the metal's
unique chemical properties.
Lithium is classified as an alkali metal.
When combined with water,
the metal forms alkalis or chemicals
that stabilize acidic solutions.
Additionally, lithium is heat resistant,
having extraordinarily high
melting and boiling points
causing it to be capable of
storing large amounts of energy.
Lithium is also highly reactive
in that it readily loses
one of its electrons
to form new bonds, thereby
creating a positive charge.
All together these
properties allow the metal
to serve as the receiving point
of negatively charged particles
helping create a powerful
electrical current
in lithium batteries.
But because of lithium's reactivity,
it does not naturally occur
in its pure elemental metal form.
It's often found as a
component of chemical compounds
and sourced from hard rock minerals,
sea water or salt water
reservoirs called brines.
Lithium deposits are
scattered around the globe
but over 75% of the world's
entire supply of lithium
is found in Chile and Bolivia.
Within the past few decades,
the presence of lithium in
these South American countries
has drawn the attention of
federal and commercial entities
from around the world
hoping to extract one of
the most sought-after,
natural resources on the planet.
By extracting a natural
resource as valuable as lithium,
these entities may fuel and help shape
the future of technology and industry.